bonjour mesdames bonjour messieurs tout
d'abord je voudrais également à la suite
de brigitte kuster rendre hommage à
frédéric péchenard puisque c'est non
seulement un très grand flic mais c'est
également la plus grande autorité en
matière de sécurité dans ce pays et vous
avez la chance à paris de pouvoir
compter sur son expérience et son grand
professionnalisme
voilà alors il ya deux façons
il ya deux façons de parler du
terrorisme de façon qui ne sont qui sont
complémentaires
il ya deux un discours un peu savant
c'est le discours des experts que vous
pouvez entendre à la radio ou la
télévision
lorsque il se passe quelque chose dans
le monde
ce discours consiste à parler des
groupes terroristes
ce discours consiste à dresser une
cartographie de ces groupes
et pourquoi pas également à vous parler
des conflits interreligieux qui peuvent
exister et qui minent l'islam depuis on
va dire le viième siècle sur les groupes
terroristes très brièvement
on a deux principaux ennemis ne faut pas
avoir peur d'utiliser ces termes amis
ennemis il faut savoir désigner son
ennemi pour le combattre on a deux
groupes principaux qui sont
historiquement d'abord al-qaïda et puis
l'état islamique mieux connus
médiatiquement en france sous le nom de
dh alors sont deux groupes qui
s'organise on va dire un peu comme des
multinationales avec des filiales par
pays
al qaïda s'est akpa pour la péninsule
ibérique arabique pardon aqmi pour le
maghreb islamique
et puis également un lien très fort
entre al qaïda et les talibans en
afghanistan
ensuite vous avez le fameux état
islamique qui est une scission en fait
d'al qaïda avec des territoires de
prédilection pour cet état islamique qui
n'a d'état que le nom
en fait c'est un proto et à ce sont des
bandes armées qui ont pris la possession
d'un territoire et qu'ils exercent sur
ce territoire
un monopole de la violence c'est un peu
la définition de l'état mais on n'est
pas dans la structure étatique quelques
nous la connaissons en france
en occident plus généralement la syrie
bien évidemment l'irak historiquement
puisque les relations de l'état
islamique avec l'irak sont des relations
profondes à la base de l'état islamique
de death vous avez la volonté des
anciens lieutenants de saddam hussein de
reprendre le contrôle du territoire
irakien faut jamais oublier l'histoire
parce que l'histoire permet de
comprendre beaucoup de choses et puis
troisième territoire qui est en passe
d'être contrôlé par des shows par l'état
islamique c'est la libye avec la
troisième ville de l'état islamique qui
est syrte en libye ça se rapproche de
nom quand même la libye voilà pour les
groupes les territoires de conflits dans
le monde vous les connaissez je parle
exclusivement des conflits liés au
terrorisme islamique
bien sûr vous avez donc la syrie vous
avez le yémen vous avez la libye vous
avez l'irak
voilà tous ces territoires qui sont des
foyers aujourd'hui du terrorisme des
foyers de violence alors on peut dire
c'est très loin tout ça on a vu qu'avec
la crise des migrants
ces territoires lointains peuvent avoir
une incidence très immédiates sur nos
vies quotidiennes demandé aux allemands
par exemple n'oubliez pas que entre new
york et les grottes de l'est de
l'afghanistan où se terrait ben laden y
avait onze mille kilomètres accepté de
tourner le regard de détourner le regard
de ces zones lointaines de ces confins
du monde où existent ces violences
c'est prendre le risque demain d'être
confrontés à une violence à laquelle on
ne pourra pas faire face donc il ne faut
pas détourner le regard de ces zones qui
nous paraissent aujourd'hui lointaine le
monde on l'a dit depuis bien longtemps
et un village globalisé
la violence est à nos portes ça c'est le
discours géopolitique il faut avoir en
tête cette cartographie on a également
une autre façon de considérer le
terrorisme islamique
c'est de le considérer d'un point de vue
religieux et historiques
rappelez-vous que finalement le
terrorisme avant tout concerne les
musulmans entre eux interdits
et c'est la guerre entre les sunnites et
les chiites il faut l'avoir en tête
parce que ça nous permet là aussi de
comprendre la géopolitique mondiale et
ce qui est en train de se jouer
bien loin de bien loin de paris avec des
axes entre l'iran la syrie le hezbollah
alors ça c'est le premier discours qu on
vous tient habituellement à la
télévision ou à la radio
c'est un discours de géopolitique et
puis il ya un deuxième discours qu'il
faut tenir parce qu'il nous concerne
encore plus immédiatement c'est le
discours politique le discours citoyen
sur le terrorisme et c'est le discours
que l'on est en droit d'attendre des
responsables politiques que nous avons
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'état
ce discours quel est il comment -
gouvernement français je dois assurer la
sécurité de mon territoire et la
sécurité de mes ressortissants
c'est le fondement même du pacte
politique et sociale en france comme
partout dans le monde
quelle est la légitimité d'un état
quelle est la légitimité d'un
gouvernement au delà de lever l'impôt la
légitimité d'un état c'est assurer la
sécurité de ses citoyens
et là nous avons des droits à faire
valoir et nous avons des demandes et des
exigences au regard du gouvernement est
ce que vous croyez
c'est ce que l'on tente de vous faire
croire que nous allons pouvoir contrer
la menace terroriste tranquillement
assis dans notre fauteuil
est-ce que vous pensez que nous allons
pouvoir contrer la menace terroriste
sans changer nos habitudes
la réponse est non est-ce que vous
pensez que nous allons pouvoir combattre
le terrorisme sans déplacer le curseur
qui sépare la liberté et l'ordre la
réponse est non alors on nous tient des
discours de guerre au terrorisme
d'ennemis de l'intérieur on utilise un
discours guerrier les actes
quels sont les actes aujourd'hui nous
combattants aujourd'hui nous faisons la
guerre avec les moyens de la paix et
nous sommes pratiquement les seuls nous
sommes pratiquement les seuls à ne
vouloir concédé aucun avantage
nous sommes les seuls à nous vouloir ne
jamais faire d'effort de concessions en
matière de libertés toutes les libertés
nous dit-on individuelles sont sacrés il
ne faut jamais rogné un bout de liberté
moi je suis là pour vous dire la vérité
nous n'arriverons pas à combattre le
terrorisme
sans faire des concessions en matière de
libertés individuelles c'est logique
encore faut-il le dire j'ai un certain
nombre d'exemples il faut pour combattre
le terrorisme
donner davantage de moyens aux services
de renseignements vous allez me dire il
y à une loi récemment qui a été adopté
est ce que vous savez que les moyens
budgétaires qui sont consacrés
aujourd'hui aux services de
renseignements sur notre territoire pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
or les coûts de personnel représentent
47 millions d'euros
c'est une information publique qui n'est
absolument pas confidentiels 47 millions
d'euros
c'est ce que dépense la ville de lyon
pour ses actions culturelles
est-ce que vous pensez que le
renseignement qui est véritablement la
larme la plus importante pour lutter
contre le terrorisme en france ne mérite
pas un peu plus un chouïa de plus que
l'action culturelle de la métropole de
liant il faut donner des moyens
juridiques supplémentaires aux forces de
l'ordre pour lutter contre le terrorisme
en france
un préfet a la possibilité de prendre ce
qu'on appelle des mesures
d'hospitalisation d'office contre des
individus qui présente pour eux mêmes ou
par la société des menaces graves
un préfet n'a pas la possibilité de
prendre des mesures administratives
comme un internement d'urgence à
l'encontre d'une personne qui présente
une dangerosité importantes en matière
d'ordre public
il faut pour cela des éléments qui
relèvent de la procédure pénale il faut
des preuves matérielles et parfois on
n'a pas de preuves on a des indices on a
un sentiment un préfet aujourd'hui n'a
pas la possibilité d'internés
administrativement à titre préventif ne
serait ce que pendant 48 heures 72
heures un individu qui présentent un
risque pour votre sécurité
ensuite on à schengen quelle aubaine
schengen par les terroristes la liberté
de circulation
il faut savoir que toutes les personnes
qui ont frappé le territoire français
les britanniques qui ont frappé le
territoire britannique ont des
nationalités britannique ont des
nationalité française ce sont des gens
qui peuvent circuler librement dans
l'espace schengen sans avoir de comptes
à rendre
je voudrais vous parler également du
désarmement pénal il y a un lien
nous l'avons vu ces dernières années en
france direct et immédiat entre le
terrorisme et l'islam au délinquance
c'est un gros mot on ne peut pas le dire
mais tous les spécialistes le savent il
y a un lien direct regarder le casier
pénale tout simplement des personnes qui
ont commis ces dernières années en
france des attentats ils sont presque
tous passés par la case prison
désarmé et pénalement notre pays c'est
affaiblir nos moyens de lutte contre le
terrorisme
il faut casser ce lien casser ce lien la
fin de peine parlons également de la fin
de peine que deviennent des terroristes
qui ont été condamnés à des peines plus
ou moins lourdes et qui ressorte
librement alors même que leurs
convictions n'ont pas changé
nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il était
président de la république avait impulsé
un texte sur la rétention de sûreté qui
a été longuement et régulièrement
détricoté par la jurisprudence par le
conseil constitutionnel tout d'abord et
puis après par des pratiques politiques
est ce qu'il ne faut pas faire un peu
plus que m en résidence surveillée dans
un village de creuse ou d'auvergne des
personnes qui ont commis ou participer
directement à la commission d'attentât
en france ou à l'étranger sans doute que
si ensuite on a internet
moi je vous dit qu'internet c'est
fabuleux mais internet pour les
terroristes
c'est un tuyau de la haine c'est un
tuyau de la haine
aujourd'hui c'est l'islamisme 2.0
aujourd'hui le recrutement se fait
presque essentiellement via le web
il faut bien évidemment multiplier les
moyens de blocage et de filtrage des
sites qui servent de véhicules à la
haine islamistes je parle d'islamisme
alors bien évidemment on prendra toutes
les précautions
mais tous les islamistes radicaux ne
sont pas des terroristes mais tous les
terroristes aujourd'hui jusqu'à preuve
du contraire sont des islamistes
radicaux
alors est-ce qu'on doit s'interdire de
le dire et de se demander s'il n'ya pas
un moyen d'accentuer le contrôle sur
l'islamisme radical dans notre pays
est-ce que c'est porté à la liberté de
religion atteinte que de placer sous
surveillance
tous les prêches tous les imams qui
tiennent des propos qui incitent à la
haine
on ne peut pas tout faire au nom de la
liberté de religion
nous en sommes convaincus il suffit
simplement de se donner les moyens et la
volonté d'assurer ce contrôle voilà je
vous remercie beaucoup